[Musique]
alors voici le bureau des auteurs vous
aviez vous avez donc la sophro charles
il m'appelle jamais pas trop en vérité
j'ai fait trois longs métrages avant
avant cette série mais je découvre avec
la série un autre milieu un autre un
autre mode de fonctionnement d'habitude
j'écris mes films un peu tout seul dans
mon coin et là on travaille avec une
équipe dans une room avec 3,4 scénariste
avec des conseillers techniques avec des
coordinateur artistique avec des
consultants les gens de canal + depuis
plusieurs années notamment à rien le
sahara comme le disait si tu as un
projet de série font sans parler puis
j'avais pas à cette idée je voulais pas
faire une série pour faire une série je
voulais faire quelque chose de fort et
puis je voulais faire quelque chose qui
sont un événement quand j'allais mettre
à la série avec cette ambition de se
dire les américains ont des séries
incroyables sur l'univers du hip hop
comme comme power comme atlanta qu'un
vampire et nous on en a pas un mec qui
fait du business de voiture comme ça
avec des voitures de ce niveau là c'est
à dire coeur il est par moment
tu voi le mec à qui je pense est un mec
qui est tu vois qu'il ya un cas qui
louent un tout un bloc de parking
souterrain à vinci en trucs classiques
comme ça et puis il a 15 bagnols là
dedans lui fait ses annonces sur les
sites de bagnols l'extérieur
quand tu arrives tu peux recevoir un
garage parce qu'il a son logo nabil
automobilistes à ce combat et et
accueille dans un parking quoi tu vois
par contre les bulls la voiture là je la
garde devant ensuite elle bouge pas vous
mettez devant paerson a conduit un
dividende accor 1 arbitres sérieusement
c'est là qu'est la voiture qui arrache
le plus à la plus puissante de tout le
gard la plus puissante
ouais bah c'est celle là
[Musique]
valider ça n'est officiellement en 2017
mais ça commence dans ma tête deux ans
avant l'idée de valider est né dans les
studios d'un dj producteur qui s'appelle
dj kore avec qui je travaillais sur la
bande originale de pattaya et je passais
mes nuits dans son studio à la plaine
saint denis avec des rappeurs qui était
en train de produire et de décrire des
morceaux qu'ils allaient qui allait
contribuer à la promotion de matériel
donc j'étais très investi dans ce qu'ils
faisaient
et puis là j'étais plongée non pas comme
un auditeur mais comme un spectateur
dans le monde du rap avec tout ce côté
fascinant avec évidemment le rare
qu'elle rappelle musique mais aussi les
embrouilles qui sont très forts dans ce
métier et et je me suis dis qu'il faut
il faut faire une série on ne peut pas
en faire un film on n'aura pas assez de
temps et j'ai fini par me dire ok je
vais aller voir canal+ et et je vais
leur proposer qu'on fasse ensemble la
première série française qui se passe
dans le milieu du rap sens à ma buzz
effort [ __ ]
[Musique]
en quelques mots validé c'est
l'ascension d'un jeune mec de 25 ans
dans le milieu du rap français c'est
surtout l'histoire d'un mec qui est
propulsé dans le rap game et je me lance
une instru on peut c'est ok a laissé
partir qu'ils commencent par à ventes de
la wii dès qu'il va finir par vivre le
plus grand événement de sa vie
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire du du parcours d'un petit
rappeur qui pourrait ressembler à plein
d'autres rappeurs contemporain pas
d'aujourd'hui
t'es sûr que c'est une bonne idée de
continuer dans la musique valider une
création originale à découvrir en
avant-première en ce moment sur my canal